well we're down inside the living
quarters the sleeping quarters here
right up on the ukrainian front line uh
a few moments ago there were some loud
impacts outside and so um we've come
down into this bunker area and it we're
waiting for the all clear and it gives
us a chance to to show you around i mean
it is really really tight quarters in
here you can see
their body armor here their weapons as
well the soldiers here some of them have
been living here for a year or so and
that's a reminder that although this
latest offensive by the russians began
back on
the end of february this is a long long
war the uh commander the platoon
commander that we've been speaking to
here has been fighting since 2014 in
this area it's a long and it's a very
difficult fight um over the course of
the past half hour or so we've heard
quite a lot of impact outgoing as well
uh russian
tank and artillery incoming and they say
that at night they're dealing with that
an awful lot more now the the so-called
battle of donbass has now begun um that
was uh announced by president zielenski
up in kiev uh he he believes the russian
assault this new chapter in the war has
begun and i think that what we will see
and certainly what the commanders are
telling us here
is that over the course of the next few
days we will see an attempt by the
russians both with their artillery from
behind and their tanks further forward
to push as far forward as they can and
join the dots there are plenty of
individual villages along this front
line ukrainian villages many of the
civilians have gone but the ukrainian
military is dug in the russians will try
and join those dots to push west but
they are it's quite clear going to meet
a very fierce ukrainian resistance